- Dear D, just why is it that all
these entries are about guys?
I mean, what's the big deal?
I think my 11 year old
self knew I was gay.
(laughs)
(sign swinging)
- I fell under the nerd category.
I still fit in that category,
but I've learned to embrace it.
- I was boy crazy. I was so boy crazy.
Not much has changed.
- I was heavily involved
with theater and chorus.
I was very over achieving
when it came to the performing arts.
- That's all I cared about,
is trying to be cool to my older cousins.
- I was kind of a loser, a nerd,
I had a few friends, but
then I was also very weird.
I was weird before weird was like a thing
people like to do to brand themselves.
( staccato beats)
- Oh man.
- This summer, I met
the cutest Swedish boy.
We played soccer together.
Walked in the rain together.
- Dear Diary, forget about Andy and Nick.
How about Benj? He is so fine.
- How is it that Swedish boys,
are so much hotter than
gross American boys? (laughs)
- Benj is so hot.
He's Korean and Norwegian,
with blond tips.
- I hate my non existent
dating life so much.
Why won't Claire talk to me? Like why?
I basically did her whole
entire lab report for her.
C'mon Claire that's so savage of you.
- I really want a lead in the Wizard of Oz
but there's just two things in my way.
Brats. N and S. S is such
a brat and she sucks.
I pray to god she doesn't get Dorothy.
I want Wicked Witch of
the West, Cowardly Lion,
Scarecrow or Tin Man.
Guess what? I got cast as Dorothy.
- July 18, 2001
Today I thought I'd tell you about Zack.
Two words M. H. Major Hottie.
- This girl I have no interest in
asked to be my date to
the 8th grade formal.
But all I want to do is take Claire.
I've never felt this
way about anyone before.
I'm totally in loves with her.
Does she loves me?
I don't know.
I don't know why I thought
a plural was a good idea,
I was like 13, 14 by this time.
- March 22, 1988
You'll never believe this.
All of the popular kids
running for class president
got beaten by Andy Rebold.
This was huge because Andy,
he wore bright orange shoes,
and his motto was,
"Vote for the schmoe
with the shoes that glow"
And he won and it was a great
victory for nerds everywhere.
Thank you Andy, thank you.
- And did I mention that
he's from London, England?
Yeah, his accent makes
him ten times hotter
than he already is.
- I had my first sip of beer today,
it tasted like absolute ass.
- The dance was so fun,
the whole time we were dancing
we were staring into each other's eyes.
(gagging)
(laughing)
- I hate this, I hate beer.
I hate girls, I hate Christmas.
Only Radiohead gets me.
- I think it's so funny to have a diary.
And cathartic.
You know even when I was 11
this was really important for me to write.
- Yeah, I'm never going
to stop keeping diaries.
And I'm so happy that I have these.
No matter how freaking
embarrassing they are.
- I would tell myself the things
that make you seem weird now,
will continue to make you seem weird.
But as you get older that's kind of cool.
- ♫ The rest is still unwritten. ♫
- I'm under so much
stress of who I'm taking
to 8th grade formal.
I feel like I'm the President
of all of the states.
I mean 8th grade formal is
bigger than senior prom.
Time to get inspo from Radiohead.
( sign swinging )